could anyone resist jacob a lordy
especially a shirtless one
this is insane he and kya gerber were
spotted vacationing in los cabos mexico
over the weekend with her parents
cindy crawford and randy gerber further
fueling
romance rumors you kind of leave it up
to interpretation
a source told et earlier this month the
two seem super happy and have been
spending a lot of time together
kyle last dated pete davidson who she
split with in january
while jacob dated kissing booth co-star
joey king
it's you know
it's always been you the actor was also
previously linked to his
euphoria co-star zendaya who he gushed
about working with in 2019.
i'm a massive fan so that's when i found
out that she was gonna be in the shower
i was pretty stoked um she's a
she's she's brilliant you know she's
beautiful and she's a she's a wonderful
performer and she just
captains the ship perfectly in july et
spoke with jacob about the pressures of
dating in the public eye
and admitted that it initially bothered
him just even the fact that somebody
would could be
someone that you don't know knows your
name is quite like disembodying
um but then eventually i think
i just for me personally i just it's got
nothing to do with me you know it's like
imagine the store around the corner from
where
you are now and whatever people are
talking about it's not your business
it's kind of how it feels it's like
unfortunately just has my name involved
in it but it just it literally has
nothing to do with me it just doesn't
affect the trajectory of my life
you